MEMBER OF THE SENATE WILL COME
TO ORDER WITH THE SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
WROTE TO GULL ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKESPEAR
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. CORTESI. DO
WE DODD. RAO. ADMIN. GLASER.
GONZALEZ. GROVE. HURTADO. JONES.
LAYERED LIMÓN MAGUIRE. MENJIVAR.
MEN. NEWMAN. WHEN NEW LOW, OCHO.
A DEAL. YOU KNOW? W. RUBIO,
SEYARTO SKINNER. SMALL CUEVAS
STERN. HUMBERG WAHAB. WEINER.
WILK. MEMBERS OF CORUM. MR
PRESIDENT, I WANT TO, UH, SAY
GOOD MORNING TO EVERYONE WANT TO
INVITE THE MEMBERS TO, UH,
RETURN TO THEIR SEATS, PLEASE?
OK, UM GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE
WOULD MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE
ON THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY,
PLEASE RISE. WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN, SISTER, MICHELLE
GORMAN. AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. MR
GORMAN. AND WE GATHER IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. THIS IS A QUOTE FROM
MATILDA JOSLYN GAUGE. THE WOMEN
OF TODAY ARE THE THOUGHTS OF OUR
MOTHERS AND GRANDMOTHERS
EMBODIED AND MADE ALIVE.
MILLIONS OF WOMEN DEAD AND GONE
ARE SPEAKING THROUGH US TODAY.
GOD OF MANY NAMES AND MANY
FACES. THE THEME OF THIS YEAR'S
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY IS TO
INSPIRE INCLUSION. WE PRAY THAT
IN THIS YEAR THE WORLD'S WOMEN
WILL EXPERIENCE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
OF AND APPRECIATION FOR OUR
GIFTS OF HOSPITALITY AND
INCLUSIVITY. MAY ALL PEOPLE OF
AUTHORITY AND GOODWILL. BE
INSPIRED TO DISMANTLE THE
BARRIERS THAT KEEP WOMEN
SEPARATED FROM EACH OTHER. MAY
WE CHALLENGE THE STEREOTYPES
THAT EXAGGERATE FLAWS. AND UNDER
REPRESENT THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
WOMEN IN ALL AREAS OF SOCIETY.
MAY WE CELEBRATE THE SOCIAL,
ECONOMIC, CULTURAL, POLITICAL
AND RELIGIOUS ACHIEVEMENTS OF
WOMEN IN ALL ERAS? AND
ESPECIALLY IN OUR CURRENT DAY.
GRACIOUS GOD. HELP ALL OF US
WORK TOGETHER TO INSPIRE
INCLUSION. SO THAT THE GIFTS OF
A MORE EQUITABLE AND DIVERSE
SOCIETY CAN BENEFIT ALL PEOPLE.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME. AMEN.
MR GORMAN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL WORDS. WE APPRECIATE
YOU MEMBERS AND GUESTS. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE TO OUR
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. YES.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA
BEGIN WITH OUR AGENDA PRIVILEGE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. I DON'T
SEE ANY TO RECOGNIZE AT THE
MOMENT. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED RED.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED RED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ IN
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED WE MOVE NEXT
TO MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SENATE RESOLUTION 66
WILL BE CORRECTED UPON
ENROLLMENT. NÓ THAT'LL BE THE
ORDER OF THE DAY. I LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE, UH, SENATOR EGMOND.
SENATOR EGGMAN. THAT TARGET THAT
MR. YES. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL COME
BACK TO THAT. MOVE NEXT TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WILL BEGIN WITH SENATE THIRD
READING THIS IS ITEM 12 S¼ R 60
WITH THE SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
THIN RESOLUTION 60 BY SENATOR
OCHO RELATIVE TO WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION WEEK. SENATOR
OCHOA, BOGUT, THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MISTER.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT S¼ R 60,
WHICH PROCLAIMS MARCH THIRD
THROUGH MARCH. 9TH 2024 AS WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION WEEK. AS HER
SIXTIES RECOGNIZES WOMEN'S
INVALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. WE MUST INSPIRE FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF WOMEN TO EMBRACE
JOBS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY, WHICH IS VITAL TO THE
STATE'S ECONOMY. WOMEN REPRESENT
AN UNTAPPED RESOURCE AND
ACTIVITIES TO IMPROVE WOMEN'S
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION IN
SKILLED CONSTRUCTION JOBS. IT'S
CRITICAL IS CRITICAL, IMPORTANT
IN MEETING WORKFORCE DEMANDS AND
BUILDING A MIDDLE CLASS. WE DO
THIS THROUGH PROMOTING
VOCATIONAL EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS,
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
INITIATIVE THAT INSPIRE AND
SUPPORT GIRLS AND YOUNG WOMEN TO
PURSUE CAREERS IN CONSTRUCTION.
I ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES AND
OUR CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
PARTNERS TO JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATING WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION WE AND TO CONTINUE
WORKING TOGETHER TO BUILD A
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY THAT
WELCOMES PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS
OF LIFE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN I VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
OCHOA, VOGUE. IS THERE FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS? THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, AND, UH, I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AMAZING, UH,
HOLIDAY AND CELEBRATION I SPENT
MORNING BREAKFAST WITH ALL OF
THE WOMEN IN THEIR BOOTS AND
TOOLS, AND I WANNA SAY WE KNOW
WHAT IT TAKES. MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE WOMEN IN THE TRADES AND
WHAT IT TAKES IS A GOOD STRONG
UNION CONTRACT WITH REAL
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS WITH
REAL TRAINERS WITH COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE BUILDING STRONG AND UNION,
BUT WE'RE ALSO MAKING SURE WE
ARE TRACKING AND MONITORING TO
ENSURE THAT WOMEN GET THEIR FAIR
SHARE OF THESE PROJECTS. I AM
HONORED TO HAVE BEEN A PART OF
BUILDING SOME OF THE MOST
REVOLUTION. TOOLS UH, WITH MY
GOOD SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES,
UH, TO ENSURE THAT WOMEN IN THE
TRADES IS NOT AN EXCEPTION. IT
IS THE NORM AND WE DO THAT
THROUGH OUR STRONG PL A S¼
THROUGH OUR STRONG
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IN OUR
STRONG CONSTRUCTION IN THE
TRADES. UH, PROGRAMS AND EFFORTS
. SO I THINK THE GOOD SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION AND
I'M HAPPY TO CALL FOR EVERYONE'S
I VOTE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. WE'LL TURN NEXT TO YOUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES.
SENATOR DIAZO. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, AND I ALSO WANT TO
ADD THAT ONE THING THAT'S VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT. AND THROUGH MY
MANY YEARS OF VISITING, UH, THE
VARIOUS TRADES UNION
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IS THAT
IT ALL LEADS TO A GOOD PAYING
JOB AND CAREER AND IN THE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE ALL WANT IS A
PERMANENT PERMANENCY IN HOW
THESE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
LEAD TO REAL, UH, LONG LASTING
CAREERS AND ALSO TO GIVE THESE
WOMEN THE SUPPORT TOOLS THAT
THEY NEED WITH CHILDCARE AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER, UH, SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER TO GET
THROUGH THESE GREAT UH UH,
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. SO I,
UH, IN PARTICULAR, WANT TO
APPLAUD ALL OF THE UNION
BUILDING TRADES PROGRAMS FOR THE
EXTRAORDINARY WORK THAT THEY DO?
THANK YOU. SENATOR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS RESOLUTION
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEN NÓ
SENATOR OCHOA, VOGUE, YOU MAY
CLOSE THE DEBATE. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, AS A WIFE AND
DAUGHTER IN LAW. HAVE A
CONSTRUCTION. UH, COMPANY, UH,
OWNER I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
RESOLUTION AND REALLY, UH, WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND WOMEN
LEADING LEADING IN DIFFERENT
SPACES, ESPECIALLY IN THE ONES
THAT ARE NON TRADITIONAL, UH,
FOR WOMEN'S ROLES. I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THIS RESOLUTION THE SENATE FLOOR
THIS MORNING AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NIGHT VOTE. I'LL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED, SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HØI I
WROTE A G. I ARCH LETTO I ASHBY
BY ATKINS. I. BECKER. BY
BLAKESPEAR. HØI BRADFORD. UH,
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. UH, DALLY. I
THOUGHT I TORAZO BY EDMUND AYE,
GLASER. HØI GONZALEZ. I GROVE.
AYE, HURTADO. JONES. I LAYERED
AYE. LEMON. HØI MCGUIRE. HØI
MINAR. AM. NEWMAN. HØI WHEN AYE,
NILO. I Ó èC. HØI HØI
ARGENTINO. AYE, ROTH. I RUBIO. I
SAY ARE TO I. SKINNER. I SMALL
QUAVERS. I STERN HØI UMBERG.
AYE, WAHAB. WEINER. I WOKE AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE IN A THIRD
READING AND MOVE BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR FOR
PURPOSES OF INTRODUCTION. I'LL
TURN THE MICROPHONE BACK TO
SENATOR OCHOLA BOGA, THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK, SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MR. UH, PRESIDENT. I
WANT TO EXTEND A WARM WELCOME TO
THE MORE THAN 100 WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION WHO ARE UP IN THE
GALLERY THIS MORNING.
AND HERE TO RECEIVE THE WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION RESOLUTION ARE TWO
LEADERS IN THE INDUSTRY.
JENNIFER FRUM, OPERATIONS
MANAGER AT KITCHELL CORPORATION,
AND MEGAN SHAPIRO, PARTNER AT
RATTLE LOVES SHAPIRO. UM IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE AMONG SO MANY
PASSIONATE WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION.
MEMBERS. YOU ARE NOW WELCOME TO
JOIN THE PHOTOGRAPH. UH, IN THE
CENTER OF THE FLOOR.
ON BEHALF OF THE SENATE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL THE WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION WHO ARE HERE
WITH US TODAY. WELCOME AND
CONGRATULATIONS. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NOW. BACK TO CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM 13. THIS IS SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 117. UH,
SENATOR IS READY, SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. IN A CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 117 BY SENATOR WEINER
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL VENDING DAY
BISCUIT, SENATOR WIENER YOUR
ATTENTION, SENATOR WEINER. UH,
THANK YOU, UH, MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES. I PRESENTING US HERE
117, WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE VENDING
INDUSTRY AND DESIGNATES MARCH
7TH 2024 AS NATIONAL VENDING DAY
, UH, THE VENDING AND
CONVENIENCE SERVICES INDUSTRY
HAS EXPANDED IN RECENT DECADES
TO INCLUDE A WIDE ARRAY OF
CONVENIENCE SERVICES AND
REFRESHMENTS. THE INDUSTRY
EMPLOYEES OVER 160,000
AMERICANS. AND GENERATES AN
ECONOMIC OUTPUT OF ALMOST $3
BILLION A YEAR IN CALIFORNIA,
EMPLOYING ALMOST 12,000 PEOPLE
IN OUR STATE. UH, THE INDUSTRY
IS COMMITTED TO INCREASING THE
PERCENTAGE OF HEALTHIER FOODS
AND BEVERAGE OPTIONS AND THE
NATION'S VENDING MACHINES TO 30
3% AND IS UNIQUELY EQUIPPED TO
SERVICE FOOD, DESERTS AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND THE
NATION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN I VOTE. THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION?
FURTHER DISCUSSION MEMBERS.
YEAH. THIS RESOLUTION IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. THAT OBJECTION. I 38 0.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. WANT
TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR.
PRESIDENT. PLEASE REMOVE FILE. A
èC R 86 FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
REMOVE IT FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
DESK THE DESK WILL NOT THANK
YOU, SENATOR EMAN. UH MEMBERS. I
WANT TO, UH, SHARE WITH YOU SOME
SAD NEWS, PLEASE. I WANT TO ON
BEHALF OF THE MINORITY LEADER.
ON BEHALF OF THE MINORITY LEADER
. I WANT TO ANNOUNCE THE PASSING
OF FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
TANDE. I UNDERSTANDING. MANY OF
US KNEW HIM AND HIS SERVICE HERE
TO OUR STATE. AND WE MOURN HIS
PASSING AND SEND OUR
CONDOLENCES. TO HIS MANY FRIENDS
AND HIS FAMILY ON BEHALF OF THE
MINORITY LEADER. THANK YOU. OK
THAT WE HAVE TWO ITEMS LEFT ON
OUR AGENDA MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING
TO DO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA COME BACK
FOR MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS FOR
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. SO
ANNOUNCEMENTS WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN. GOING TO BEGIN WITH
SENATOR BECKER. SENATOR BECKER.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. BUDGET
SUB-COMMITTEE TWO ON RESOURCES.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION. ENERGY
WILL MEET IN ROOM 2215 MINUTES
AFTER THE CLOSE OF SESSION.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BECKER,
SENATOR LAIRD OF THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMITTEE WON ON
EDUCATION. WE MEET IN THE SWING
SPACE ROOM 2100 UPON ADJOURNMENT
. A. YOU, SENATOR, LAD, SENATOR
WAHAB. THANK YOU. BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE, NUMBER FIVE ON
CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION WILL MEET 15
MINUTES UPON ADJOURNMENT OF
SESSION IN ROOM 112. YOU,
SENATOR WAHAB, SENATOR MENJIVAR.
THANK THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
BUDGET SUBCOMITTEE. NUMBER THREE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WILL MEET 10 MINUTES. UH,
FOLLOWING SESSION IN ROOM, 1200,
THANK YOU AND SENATOR PADILLA.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. BUDGET
SUB NUMBER FOUR AND STATE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONVENE AT
930 IN ROOM 103 HERE IN THE
CAPITOL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS, PLEASE. UH, PLEASE NOTE
THOSE THOSE ROOMS AND TIMES.
MEMBERS IF I CAN GET YOUR
ATTENTION, PLEASE. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY. AND WE'RE GONNA
RECOGNIZE OUR COLLEAGUE, SENATOR
ROTH. SENATOR ROCK, PLEASE GIVE
HIM YOUR ATTENTION. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. YOU KNOW, I FIRST
MET MY FRIEND DÂN HANTMAN ABOUT
40 YEARS AGO. I WAS A YOUNG
ATTORNEY, THEN FAIRLY NEW TO THE
PRIVATE PRACTICE OF LAW AND DÂN
HAD JUST MOVED INTO THE PRIVATE
PRACTICE OF LAW FROM PUBLIC
SERVICE LAW WITH INLAND COUNTY'S
LEGAL SERVICES. I HAVE TO TELL
YOU. I WAS IMMEDIATELY IMPRESSED
WITH HIM WITH HIS INTELLECT, HIS
COMPASSION FOR OTHERS HIS
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
AND HIS WORLDLY EXPERIENCE. DÂN
WAS A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN. BORN
IN L, A. HE ATTENDED U èC, L A
AND U èC BERKELEY, GRADUATING
WITH A DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE. BUT SOON AFTER
GRADUATING, DAN'S PASSION FOR
HELPING OTHERS TOOK OVER. AND HE
VOLUNTEERED TO SERVE IN THE
PEACE CORPS IN THAILAND. THERE.
HE TAUGHT ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE TO HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. AND HE LEARNED TO
SPEAK THAI FLUENTLY. WHEN DAN'S
TWO YEAR STINT WITH THE PEACE
CORPS WAS OVER, HE LOOKED FOR
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN
THAILAND, AND HE FOUND ONE WITH
AMERICAN UNIVERSITY ALUMNI
ASSOCIATION LANGUAGE CENTER. BY
THE END OF HIS SECOND TOUR. SIX
YEARS LATER, DÂN HAD ESTABLISHED
11 LANGUAGE CENTERS THROUGHOUT
THAILAND, ALL TEACHING ENGLISH
AS A SECOND LANGUAGE. I KNOW
THERE ARE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF THAIS THAT LEARNED
ENGLISH FROM DÂN AND DÂN MADE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
LIFELONG FRIENDS OVER THERE. AND
I'M CERTAIN THEY STILL TALK
ABOUT THE AMAZING DÂN HANTMAN IN
THAILAND TODAY. WELL DÂN
EVENTUALLY RETURNED TO THE
STATES GRADUATED FROM LAW SCHOOL
AND PRACTICED LAW WITH THE REST
OF US IN RIVERSIDE. BUT HE WAS A
CUT. ABOVE THE REST. HE NEVER
LOST HIS COMPASSION FOR OTHERS
AND HIS COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC
SERVICE. HIS LAW PRACTICE
CENTERED ON HELPING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE THE ELDERLY AND THE
DISABLED AND HIS COMMUNITY
ACTIVITIES REFLECTED THAT SAME
COMMITMENT TO OTHERS. FROM THE
TIME HE SPENT AS THE PRESIDENT
OF OUR LOCAL BAR ASSOCIATION,
IMPROVING THE DELIVERY OF LEGAL
SERVICES TO OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO HIS
WORK WITH OUR CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, IMPROVING THOSE VERY
SAME COMMUNITIES, DÂN NEVER
SEEMED TO STOP. AND WE WERE ALL
BETTER FOR IT. AS YOU KNOW, AS
YOU WELL KNOW, THIS WEEK IS
PRIMARY ELECTION WEEK. AND IT
REMINDS ME SO VERY, VERY MUCH OF
DÂN. WHY YOU ASK BECAUSE
ELECTIONS IN THE RUN UP TO THEM
SEEMED TO ENERGIZE HIM. AT ONE
POINT SEVERAL YEARS AGO, HE RAN
FOR ELECTION. AS A CANDIDATE FOR
CONGRESS. HE DIDN'T WIN. BUT
THAT DID NOT DIMINISH DAN'S
ENTHUSIASM. FOR THE PROCESS.
DURING THE RUN UP TO EVERY
SINGLE ELECTION, INCLUDING SOME
OF MINE YOU WOULD FIND DÂN
STANDING ON THE CORNER OF
CENTRAL AVENUE IN CANON CREST
DRIVE, A RATHER PROMINENT STREET
CORNER IN RIVERSIDE, WEARING HIS
TRADEMARK BIG SOMBRERO. AND
WAVING HIS FAVORITE CANDIDATES
YARD SIGN. FORTUNATELY FOR ME,
SOMETIMES IT WAS ONE OF MINE.
WELL, DÂN. WASN'T ON THAT STREET
CORNER FOR THE PRIMARY THIS YEAR
. SADLY HE PASSED AWAY ON
FEBRUARY 14. THIS ELECTION
SEASON. I WILL THINK ABOUT DÂN
EVERY TIME I DRIVE BY THAT
CENTRAL AVENUE LOCATION. I KNOW
HE'S STILL THERE IN SPIRIT. AND
PERHAPS HE'S EVEN WAIVING ONE OF
MY SIGNS. WE WILL ALL MISS DÂN,
HIS BIG SIGN AND HIS EVEN BIGGER
SOMBRERO. A LOT. I'D ASK THAT
YOU KEEP DAN'S LIFE PARTNER,
MARSHA GILMAN. AND HIS FAMILY IN
YOUR PRAYERS. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ROTH. THE SENATE EXTENDS ITS
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FRIENDS AND
FAMILY. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE SENATE
JOURNAL. THERE WAS NÓ OTHER
BUSINESS BEFORE THE AND TODAY,
SENATOR MAGUIRE THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, UH, QUICK
NOTE TO ALL THOSE WHO ARE ON THE
BALLOT THIS WEEK. THANK YOU FOR
STEPPING UP TO BE ABLE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. I HOPE
YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND, A
WELL DESERVED BREAK. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY. MARCH 11TH 2024 AT 2
P.M. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MCGUIRE. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
3:30 P.M. AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT 2
P.M.